[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in carson palmer who uh
joins us weekly appearance here how did
things change after yester or last week
at this time when you mentioned mike
tomlin's name
yeah they uh that got a little bit of
attention for me throwing a wild card
out there
hey
us trojan fans can dream that that's a
dream scenario picking up a guy like
mike tomlin uh going to usc but it's a
wild card
and that got a little bit of attention
obviously did you get any phone calls
after that
i got some phone calls i got some phone
calls and lots of texts
but again it's a wild card it's a it's a
it's a daydream by me and and probably
all other ufc fans across the nation
and and i wondered about that because
you did say it i even said it after you
did and said it the next day this is a
wish list you're not reporting mike
tomlin was interested in usc it's usc
there's probably quite a few names on
that list
that obviously you don't want to mention
has wild cards now but there are
probably some other
notable coaches on there
that people might be surprised that usc
would think hey who knows let's take a
shot is that is that a fair assessment
of the hiring search here
that's all it is is an assessment i'm
not sitting in meetings with athletic
directors and athletic program and
boosters
i'm listening to
news bites here and there from from all
over the country like you are and
there's a lot of wild cards i mean i
probably the most notable one that
everybody ties is luke fickle because of
the relationship that mike bone and luke
fickle had as mike hired luke at the
university of cincinnati but
there's a lot of interest in this job
and and the reason is it's usc it's it's
not your your usual run-of-the-mill
college we're talking about sc so
um
there's a bunch of names that that are
being thrown out there and as the season
progresses it's really fun to follow
along and see whose name gets thrown in
the hat
what was your reaction to mike tomlin's
reaction
i got a the first text i got was from my
brother saying hey mike tomlin's going
to be hot in his first press conference
next week
and he was yeah he was and uh you know
it's it's it's not fair of me to to all
of a sudden everybody jump on the
bandwagon and and throw that out there i
was just daydreaming out loud with you
dan you asked me a question directly who
who i'd i'd be excited about and who i'd
like and i'd love to see mike tomlin got
a lot of love and respect for playing
against him for 10 years and then
buddies that have played for him but
again it's early there's a lot of
football left to be played there's going
to be another college name another
college coach that gets hot here and
gets his team
into a big bowl game or into the
playoffs maybe and and then that name
will be thrown in the ring so uh it's
just fun to to talk about and digest all
these names and all these guys as we get
down here to the end of this season
and luke fickle's name came up a while
ago and then i had a source say luke
doesn't want to leave the midwest
um
do you understand that that you know i
mean when you go to you're uprooting
your family you go to southern
california i mean it's it's a whole
different lifestyle than what he's got
in cincinnati right now but could you
see him
wanting to stay in the midwest or not
wanting to go out and kind of trying to
immerse himself into southern california
uprooting your family is part of the
deal that's part of the job as as
coaches
bounce around from team to team no
nobody just signs a contract with one
team and stays there their entire career
very very rarely so
uh women that get interested in and
coaches know that before they say yes or
i do
they understand that that's the coach's
lifestyle it is what it is it's year
after year couple years here a couple
years there
but at the end of the day you know
there's only a handful of elite you know
creme de la creme programs the alabamas
usc's texas and so on and so when you
have a chance to leave uh and and be
really happy and comfortable in your
your your home state or maybe
your kids are happy at school your
wife's happy in the neighborhood but
when you have a chance to leave for one
of those premier programs it's
definitely a discussion around the
dinner table with that family all right
let's dive into the nfl carson palmer
joining us worst loss of the weekend
turned in by who
i think it's a tie between what happened
uh in in new orleans with tampa i mean
tampa really had a chance to separate
themselves in that division and take a
big lead uh as well as cincinnati did
cincinnati should be sitting here at six
and two they're five and three with a
big loss in new york to the jets they
really had a chance to distinguish
themselves in the asc north after that
big beating they put down on on
baltimore a couple weeks ago that gave
them the outright lead in that division
had they won unfortunately both those
teams lost now the nfc south and the afc
south are pretty wide open
for a champion because both those teams
are tied at the top and derrick henry
looks like he might be done for the year
gonna need uh foot surgery there yeah i
was wondering who's the team to beat in
the nfc right now
it's still tampa it's still the
defending champs um you know i i think
they have
probably the best defense in the game
right now coached by todd balls who's an
unbelievable defensive coach and you got
tom brady so they're still the team to
knock off in the nfc yeah i was
wondering you know it feels like it's
going through green bay because that
division is bad
and they've had some pretty impressive
wins you know the rams are kind of
quietly
building up the win seattle's not good
uh san francisco hasn't been good
arizona came back down to earth a little
bit so i i don't know i probably look at
green bay right now even though if you
said both are healthy i'd say tampa
would probably be the most well-rounded
team there where do the rams fit in in
that
equation
the rams are the sleeper it's kind of
funny being based in los angeles you're
not hearing a ton about them for the
most part it seems like the bigger you
know the major metropolis cities seem to
get a lot of attention when they're
doing well for some reason the rams are
just kind of plugging along and beating
everybody they should be and and winning
pretty pretty easily in most their games
and nobody's giving them the credit and
the love which doesn't make any sense i
mean they finally have
you know a top 10 top five maybe
quarterback in the league and so they're
a team that's kind of sneaking along and
nobody's really talking about them
talent for talent i mean you look at you
put l.a next to to green bay and i think
the better rosters in la
but green bay's got aaron rodgers so
that's always the wild card but at the
end of the day at this point in the
season i always go with a defending
champ if they're still playing well and
they're they're at the top and that's
tampa and i i think they're they're
going to come down to it i would love to
see in the nfc championship green bay
tampa and we might end up seeing that
explain to me bill belichick going on
the road
against the charger team that everybody
has christened as they're one of the
elite teams and justin herbert the
quarterback you want to build around
and bill ends up bringing his team out
there and picking up the win i
that one really surprised me
what about you yeah yeah i know there's
a lot of hype there was a lot of hype
three weeks ago and on the chargers and
that's died off now they've lost a
couple over the last three weeks
and they ran into the buzz saw that is
that is bill belichick at the end of the
day he always does something to throw
you for a loop as a quarterback he
always plays he always seems to play
really really well and have a good
defensive game plan against these next
hot shot quarterbacks that people are
getting excited about
so he did what bill belichick does he
slowed him down he created a couple
turnovers they had some really
interesting plays where they were
bringing different fire zones and got
some sacks and got some hits and got
justin herbert off of his spot in the
pocket and made him move and delayed the
pass so he bill did what he what he
typically does year in year out which is
frustrating young quarterback that
everybody's kind of like you said
christened is the next greatest thing
and he slowed him down and mack jones
ended up playing better and looking
better as that game went on
carson once had one of those moments
where
and i'm sure you know the feeling or
been in it close to it but you know you
switch his hands to throw it and he's in
the end zone and throws that
interception like is it is it the
younger quarterback that's trying to
make something always happen because
they they're not that far removed from
college i mean i guess carson would be
considered a veteran now so the even
less of an excuse there but what what is
the feeling like when you're in the
moment you're still trying to make
something happen but you shouldn't
he's far too veteran to make that
mistake you do see that with a young guy
and mac jones it's okay
um you know even even a younger
quarterback first couple starts but
carson's been in the league far too long
and that team is is built
uh to the point where you can't make
that kind of play as a quarterback that
team is built to run the ball and
they've done that extremely effectively
and that team is built to play great
defense and not turn the ball over
unfortunately
you can't do that
when you have a team like that and you
don't have a clear-cut number one guy to
throw the ball up to you know 50-50
balls and explosive offense that team is
built to play great defense control the
ball
with the running game with a short
passing game and not turn it over and
unfortunately he's turned it over far
too many times and you know he's the
first to admit it he said it after the
games like i cannot make those plays he
knows it and he's just carson's always
kind of been one of those guys that just
can't give up he just can't say quit you
know he just is always fighting for an
extra yard he's always thinking he can
pull some sort of superhuman uh superman
play out of something that it should
there's just nothing there sometimes you
just need to eat it and take a safety
sometimes you just need to take the sack
or throw it out of the bounds and
unfortunately he's too far along in his
career to continuously make those
mistakes
what's it like in film study when you
know
you've you've thrown a bad interception
or a fumble or whatever it is and you
know it's coming up like what's that
feeling like as you're sitting there and
just waiting to see if the coach just
piles on
that's the worst part of the week you're
you're surrounded by your teammates and
your peers and
you there's no doubt you're playing for
the fans and you're playing for for the
fan base and for your family and all
that
but more importantly carson's playing
for his teammates and when when you let
your teammates down it's not the it's
not the fear of letting a fan down or
the fan base down it's when you let your
teammates down and it's one of those
deals you're sitting in that meeting and
you know that play is coming up in four
plays and three plays and two plays and
then here it is
and you just slowly start sinking in
that seat your face starts getting
really red and hot almost like you have
a temperature your temperature is rising
because you're surrounded by your tier
your peers and those are the guys that
are putting in their best work all week
long preparing for that game preparing
for that moment to be in that moment
with a chance to have a game-winning
drive and it's not the fans you let down
it's that hurts it's it's the guys in
the room they're sitting next to you and
sitting behind you
those are the ones that hurt the most is
when you're watching it with your
teammates and you know you let all those
guys down but you
do you have to explain it in the moment
during film session do are you allowed
to say anything
every player has made it it's not always
a quarterback sometimes it's an
offensive tackle that on a big drive
just got his hands too high and
and wrapped his arm around the defender
and they throw a flag for 15 yarders and
that's what caused the loss or a missed
tackle or a missed dropped interception
at this point in guys careers once they
make it to the nfl as great as all those
players are in the locker room they've
all made a a
massive mistake that lost a game for a
team or lost a game and know how that
feels so
nothing needs to be said you don't need
to stand up and go hey my bad everybody
everybody knows that you're bad you
threw it to the other team that's you
are bad so there's no there's no uh
explanation needed everybody knows what
it you know what it is the chiefs
tonight against the giants and
everybody's going to have an opinion
tomorrow one way or another about the
chiefs
can they play
a conservative style of offense
that's not how they're built that's the
that's especially not how they're built
on the back end of their defense their
that defense is built to play with the
lead so playing conservative and running
it and um you know that's just not who
they are but this is a statement game if
there's ever been a statement game this
is a bad new york giants team there's a
lot going on in kansas city there's some
players going back and forth with the
fan base and
there's a lot of distractions and at the
end of the day we've all heard it a
million times a win
cures all and it just covers everything
up just win and it puts all the back and
forth that the kansas city fan base has
had with tyron matthew and a couple
other players it covers that up until
next week and then the week after but
this is a they need to blow this team
out by 18 points i mean this is a bad
team against the team that's been been
representing the afc in in in the super
bowl the last couple years so this this
is a game that they need to win
decisively they need to put this team
away early they cannot sit out there and
run the ball and check it down patrick
mahomes needs to be patrick for homes he
needs to throw the ball over the top
be explosive and win by a couple scores
i don't think you said anything
inflammatory today
congratulations hopefully you have a a
nice weekend here and no text messages
from your brother or phone calls or
anything like that carson
yeah you didn't set me up today oh
i didn't set you up
you know it was one of those where i
threw up a 50 50 ball and you came down
with it
i mean you could have let it fall
like i said earlier we can drift we can
all all us usc trojan fans we can dream
we can dream about tomlin or
you throw another name out there and
i'll say yeah sure he'll leave for the
job how about belichick do you think
belichick is on usc's wish list
i have nothing but tremendous respect
for belichick but i cannot see him in
college i cannot see him in in a room
with that dry sense of humor and just
that overall dryness we need energy at
that level you got 18 to 21 years old
you need energy you need up tempo
and i don't see bill changing his way
for college is pete carroll on the list
i don't think pete can go back just
because he can't he can't do what he did
already i mean he set the bar up here
and won national championship after
national championship if he goes back
there's it's almost impossible to
replicate that so i think that is the
only reason he he looks at that job and
says i don't want it i can't go back i
can't do what i did
back in the
mid 2000s again
let's stir it up though let's get
another headline how about nick saban
uh why on earth would nick leave alabama
to go to sc
i don't know okay
lane kiffin is lane kiffin on the list
no that very that that ship has sailed
that plane that
plane has has flown you know that plane
has has left the terminal yeah it is yes
i i don't see lane i mean they already
gave him a shot i was uh somebody was
asking me the other day about ed ogdran
edward ron's already had a shot um i'd
be surprised if it was either of those
two guys
all right see i tried to get set you up
and get another headline here you know
it's i'm sorry it's just
it's in me it's just it just naturally
comes out of you you're setting people
up it's just like brady throws touchdown
passes i mean it's just it's it's just
there natural yeah it's just natural
yeah it's a gift it's a gift god gave it
to you
[Laughter]
thank you carson
thanks dan that's carson palmer he uh
joins us courtesy of level select cbd
level select cbd for next level relief
visit levelselectcbd.com